ukraine now the country has not been
fighting back against the russians alone
and the help from other countries goes
beyond supplying weapons and food
thousands of americans acting on their
own have joined the ukrainian forces
they have been part of some essential
operations across the country alongside
other men who never imagined that they
would become soldiers deborah patta
spoke to some of them
ukraine may be outgunned
but it's put up a fierce defense against
russia's military might
and there's nothing like an underdog to
galvanize support
just over a month ago ukrainian artem
was a singer in a heavy metal band as a
person i like more to create than to
destroy
now this poet turned warrior sleeps in
an underground bar turned bunker with
the rest of his ukrainian unit
unhesitatingly he stepped forward to
defend his homeland he's fighting with
his heart
he's not alone ukrainians of every age
have joined up
and over 20 000 foreign fighters have
signed up to fight alongside them among
them at least 3 000 americans
like this cincinnati native and former
u.s serviceman alex kalembo as russian
tanks rolled into ukraine he was on the
first plane over there it's something
that's going to be in the history books
you kind of
feel like i need to be part of it and
part of it he is he serves with artem in
a special unit with no promise of
financial reward right now we're all
volunteers
which
is fine by me they feed me they give me
ammunition
but he concedes they are in desperate
need of sniper rifles and night vision
gear
they've been in some of the bloodiest
battles of this war including urban
where ukrainians managed to stop the
russian advance on the capital for now
as civilians fled for their lives
and what's your biggest fear i'm not
really afraid of dying but i guess i'm
afraid of losing
but this is no romantic adventure it's
war
which this other american volunteer
found out the hard way hey dude how are
you with a constant threat of death
columbus parents back home are concerned
but supportive he has done something
that he believes in
and uh and he is helping the ukrainian
people
i'm proud of him for that
artem and his unit feel the same way
we welcome all the help that we can get
to fight their common enemy to the end
what's your message to other russian
soldiers and to vladimir putin i just
wish them death i just despise them for
all what they're doing
and columbus unit has already played a
vital role in pushing back russian
troops just 20 miles from where we are
here in the capital vlad
patta and key for us thank you deborah
wow the ukrainian people have inspired a
lot of people to join with them even
though i what that one man said
where he said i'm not afraid of dying i
just don't want to lose
because people see many believe the
injustice that has happened to the
ukrainian people they go i got to do
something yes i admire people that can
do that there's nothing like an underdog
to galvanize support my concern for
these individuals is how they would be
treated by the russians if they're
captured because they might not be
protected under geneva conventions uh
the way you would treat a combatant a
soldier if you are what they might
consider a mercenary meaning you've been
recruited from abroad to come and fight
in this war that could be probably the
fact that the military has already made
that clear too they will not be treated
well the fact that they are making the
decision to fight for another country is
admirable it reminds me of a madeleine
albright quote i have to say i've been
talking about it all week with my family
what people have the capacity to choose
they have the ability to change these
people are choosing something in order
to make change that is powerful they
believe in it they believe i don't have
that i admire them though yeah i don't
have that
it's uh well yeah that's exactly why
these people are inspirational yes yes
going out there